and I do think an Emmy would be really
cool because I do consider myself a
television actress I consider that to be
my genre that I focused on that I'm
proud of but truly the thing that made
me want to be an actress was theater and
the thing I want to do most is theater
and to have the top prize in that what
is it about like the immediate like the
connection with the audience
I think it's that feeling that you're
this is live this is a you know that is
something that you you're not doing take
two and because I've done a lot of
theater too but um it's it's exhausting
it is you know you're doing like if you
do Broadway you could be doing eight
shows a week yes and you know doing the
same thing over and over is not easy for
me I have a DeeDee really real bad and I
totally get that I think for me it's
that what you get to tell the characters
whole story in one night so you don't
have to stretch out the journey and the
arc and the story and all the emotional
beats over a month of filming you get to
do it all at once in one sitting in 1/2
hour chunk and I love going on the whole
character journey until the whole story
and then when you do it again it's
really exciting to me how you can
completely intend to say a line the same
way as last night but then it comes out
a little different and then there's like
a little thrill it's like it's like the
same thrill is when you're kind of like
you know sneaking around it's like well
that line went different and listen how
they reacted and then whoa get back on
track sneaking around like okay I need
to make very clear and put in another
term here's what I'm trying to say I
know you're trying this I am trying to
say like yeah we've all we all were in
our 20s right yeah I think in your 20s
you're like you have a boyfriend but
then you're out and someone flirts with
you and you're like I'll take it
it's like that it's just like a little
thrill no I mean look it doesn't matter
if you're if you're not married who
cares if you're never cheated on your
husband then that's not the who cares
correct
okay good we agree Ryan are you a
cheater no have you ever cheated no have
you ever flirted I mean I'm not good at
their industry have you ever had an
indiscretion an indiscretion is this a
horrible conversation I am sweating
really